brought to you by the PlayStation
original series powers watch the series
premiere for free on March 10th at
playstation com video games are just
filled with all manner of tough and
powerful protagonists but there are some
who stand above the rest from the world
creating to the world destroying here
are our picks for most powerful video
game protagonists in partnership with
our sponsors Playstations original
series powers let's start with the sort
of human but not really category
featuring dante and bayonetta these guys
are actually pretty similar both in
power and straight-up badassery on top
of both of them have been consistently
perfect hair and wardrobe Dante is half
demon and can take on a devil trigger
state that unleashes his full
supernatural ability he fights monsters
dozens of times larger than him i haveth
the bayonetta is also pretty familiar
with dante also has been known to get
impaled on his own sword and be totally
nonplussed meanwhile bayonetta is an
umbran witch who fights with a
combination of stealthy lethal attacks
and her which time ability where she
speeds up while time is slowed down
dante and bayonetta also both have the
power to deliver snappy one-liners to
their foes as they land they're
finishing blows dude
Kratos of the character whose might
doesn't need much justification he kills
gods like regularly Kratos his signature
move is getting mad and then getting
stronger and then killing the things his
name literally means power you only have
to play God of War for 20 minutes to
kill off your first great mythical being
in an appropriately brutal fashion and
it just keeps escalating from there to
date he's killed 23 greater mortal
beings that we know of including
household names like Aries Athena
Poseidon Hades and Zeus there are a
bunch of ordinary fictional humans
who've come across superpowers by a
nuclear waste infectious diseases or
what have you Alex Mercer was one of
those who got particularly lucky or
particularly unlucky depending on your
perspective an infection imbues Mercer
with all sorts of insane powers he can
shape-shift and morph his body into
weapons and he has superhuman speed
agility and insurance which lets him
jump 10 stories in the air and survive
Falls from any height bullets passed
right through his body and he has
unlimited stamina so there are no cool
downs on his super speed and whatnot as
if that wasn't power enough he also has
superhuman senses he can absorb people
like whole people and he's basically
invincible well that's right up until
the second game where the protagonist
James Heller takes him down you know who
else can absorb people though Kirby that
constantly underestimated pink fall of
doom Kirby might not seem all that
terrifying but considering he can inhale
you hole and take your powers whatever
advantage you once had is gone he also
serves rainbow lines and his puffy pink
skin makes him pretty much unkillable
not to mention turning into a heavy-ass
weight at a moment's notice but if you
think he's a challenge you might want to
consider going up against Maxwell from
scribblenauts alright I know you weren't
expecting scribblenauts to come up in
this video but consider that Maxwell
could definitely
be the worst of the lot you know if he
wasn't saddled with that ether everybody
rating that just let you use curse words
Maxwell can imagine anything and make it
into a reality he can then use those
items on or with anything and anyone in
the environment even Alex Mercer would
have his work cut out for him against
Maxwell in his magic notebook you know
if Maxwell ever decided to take off the
headphones and absurd rooster hat and
get down to business there are so many
powerful characters that I don't have
time to mention but I thought I should
end this video on the right note and
that's with Asura from asuras wrath
Asura is like Kratos on steroids he's a
demigod who kills gods and can assume
several deadly forms one of those is
Asura the destructor where he exhibits
godlike power and is literally bigger
than the earth he destroys stars and
planets and eventually manages to take a
hit from the creator of the universe
which results in him getting knocked
back oh no I'm sorry not Asura that's
right the creator of the universe gets
knocked back Asura is just stupidly
kick-ass powerful let me know which
video game protagonists NAB's your picks
the most powerful and why I'll catch
again next week